I'm Harry Williams I have my otogi hi
I'm Jonathan Joseph this is Sports Bible
meets
[Music]
there's more the coaches I reckon we're
fortunate fortunate enough to be coached
by a put your tough operators you know
they push us really hard
I reckon like Tour de France that's the
hardest boy in the world or its martial
arts can be pretty tough as well Oh
McGregor money to my first answer still
stands long-distance cycling in the
world the mountains
I reckon for me you know one of the
proudest moments I've had is scare my
first cap it was a special day for
myself for my family everyone involved
in my my career that's father I think
within the winning the Six Nations is
it's very special it's you know a very
competitive competition but then to when
the Grand Slam was was unbelievable to
me that would that be you know my
highlight I'd say first name is Mario
first cap over in Argentina it was just
you don't really understand how big it
is now you know it's a massive occasion
and when you finally first cut and
you'll realize just know work hard train
hard
don't let make sure that you're you you
know you you value the little things in
your career and just make sure your
enjoyment stays high have fun have all
the fun you can when you're young now we
still we still have some fun but when
you're young when you can you just ask
my advice have fun okay that's all yeah
thank you how you will because when
you're older that diminishes a little
bit abilities got mortgage have fun
[Music]
having decent kit is very important
because we travel halfway across the
world we're always Roy's and everywhere
on a day-to-day basis so having kit that
you feel comfortable and look good in is
very important it is I agree that I'm an
Arsenal fun so growing up it was
was back in the invincible era soul of a
lot of great players there but my
favorite player in that period was
Vieira I wouldn't necessarily say I
faith what will I get
but I would like to be I like to be like
you I think I'd be
yeah I'm pretty similar to Messi best
footballer can you be a bit like yeah
and been right by that he's favored yeah
all the Heskey moments I'd say Dean the
Titan Austin central defender for Palace
some 15 years ago good play
[Music]